with you and Shawn as well I mean you
guys just look so happy at a moment is
that the case yeah we're pretty happy I
really really love him a lot
kamila Kibeho just dropped the l word
and pretty much finally confirmed in an
interview her romance with Shawn Mendes
yeah we're pretty happy I really really
love him a lot
Camilla is spilling d on Capital FM's
breakfast show she also talks about
working with her man on there hitch
senorita's
[Music]
there was like a period where we didn't
hang out as much just cuz we were both
busy and this song was really fun
because we got to just hang out again
like we did on the song we did before I
know he did last summer which is when we
got really close this was just like you
know we were like of course romance
rumors have been swirling Shawn and
Camilla for a while though he's
previously been pretty coy when asked
[Music]
but let's not forget they've pretty much
solidified their status with this video
we just finally how you really guess
yeah
yeah now Camila is currently gearing up
to release a new song called cry for me
reportedly about her ex Matthew Hussey
[Music]
it'll be on her upcoming album romance
which doesn't have a release date just
yet but she's been teasing it I'm really
happy and I feel very I don't I feel
like really in touch with my emotions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]